thank you all for coming I don't
recognize any of you nor can I recall
why I'm here now without further ado
what kind of doctor from scratch my name
is Aaron Pell you'll find me on the
Internet at various locations that are
displayed on the screen and I'm from
Australia
if the accent hasn't given that away yet
and I were free consultancy company back
in Australia a couple years ago we're
finding that a lot of our clients were
wanting to understand docker they wanted
to work out how it could be used but
when we were trying to understand it
ourselves to be able to help them what
we were finding is that people were
talking about all kinds of things that
imbued all infrastructure how you do
containerized applications micro
services Bluegreen deployments where
your hot swapping containers that are
running in a kubernetes cluster in a KS
or a CI or whatever the orchestrator
might be and whatever cloud platform it
is and you try to replicate your dev
environment exactly in production and
all this stuff was like that's
everything that they were talking about
that is not what this talk is about we
are going to start from the basics
because what we found was that it was
great to learn all this stuff about how
you could use markup services in you
know in these kubernetes pods that could
scale out to as big as you could ever
possibly need but if you didn't
understand the basics and it really
wasn't a whole lot that we could find
that was gonna help people understand
the basics so that's what this talks
about we're gonna be starting from
scratch and that's a little joke that
I've got in there that hopefully you'll
also find funny by the end of the talk
if not I will just try and move on
so if you're looking for something a bit
more advanced than than that feel free
to wander off to one of the other
sessions I will not be offended just
leave a green slip in the front because
I did warn you that this is gonna be an
introduction talk but before we get
started I want to talk about some useful
terminology to know when we're talking
about docker docker is not a virtual
machine this is a common misconception
that people have particularly when
they're first coming to docker is arts
it's basically just a VM particularly
you're running it on Windows and you run
around Linux containers you're running
it in a VM so it's just a VM right it's
not really it's actually yeah it's great
out of Linux
we do have windows containers now
there's slightly different conceptually
they solve the same sorts of problems
but architectural II in the way they're
implemented is very different because of
the differences between the windows and
the Linux kernel but in Linux it really
grows from the the things you can do
with inside of the colonel just natively
using like chroot namespaces see groups
and stuff like that it's it's really
about having user space isolation of
processes that's ultimately what docker
is about and that's what the container
is is it is a process isolation so when
working with docker any any container
engine runtime we have images images are
our starting point this is what we will
build it's what we share with other
developers on the teams what we push to
different environments role to
production etc but that that is our our
base starting point is is an image from
an image we run a container so container
is actually just a running instance of
an image
I still and then will accidentally say
container when I main image and vice
versa so I apologize if I make that kind
of wording mistake but there they are
very different like I said a container
is run from an image and image is just
something that lives on a hard drive
essentially or in a in a repository
somewhere and then finally we have a
host the host is the thing that's going
to be running the containers and the
images are stored within so my Windows
10 laptop here is is a host for Windows
containers and Linda's containers
well the Linux containers are
technically running inside of a Linux
virtual machine either in hyper-v or in
moe-moe via Linux running inside of
hyper-v if you're running on Linux you
can use the the native Linux install as
the host if we're talking about a zaroor
GCP or AWS then the host is whatever
that cloud platform is providing so this
is pretty typical with docker CLI
command we start with the doctor CLI
tool docker unsurprisingly we then give
it a command that we want execute run
images
et cetera et cetera we'll see some of
these commands throughout the rest this
talk we then provide it with some
options of things that need to go into
that command that we're going to be
running so I'm providing two options in
this case
- IT which is telling it to be an
interactive container that we're
starting up and - - erm which will tell
the container to clean itself up when
it's when it's stopped we'll see that in
action shortly we then provide some
arguments to it for to run a container I
need to tell it the image so that's that
first bit there it's a bun - I'm telling
you I want to run the bun - image and
then what command do I want to execute
when that container is started up and
then executes pin bash and that's
basically for my slides I figured that
standing here and now doing a slide deck
for 48 hours going to be Philly and
interesting particularly from a doctor
introduction talk instead I'm gonna jump
over to the command line so I've got
just a center prompt here I'm using
wsl on Windows but this could be done
from PowerShell if you're using a
Windows machine and probably do it from
cmd.exe but no one should do that if
you're on Linux you your shell flavor of
choice and I have line of code here that
is actually what we basically just saw
on that slide so I'm using docker run -
- so - i.t because I want an interactive
container something that I can connect
into I'm telling you the platform I want
around is Linux this is dated for if
you're using Windows because Windows can
run both Linux and Windows containers
simultaneously you need to tell which
operating system platform you want to
execute on by default Windows will use a
Windows container unfortunately there is
no windows or bun - container so it's
very image so double fall over there
Todd you I was probably going to use our
imaging container interchangeably by
accident so we try and run up one - on
Windows and they would fail because that
doesn't exist so we tell it's links and
then - all right command so let's
execute that and see what happens so now
my prompts changed because I'm now
connected into this running Ubuntu
instance and this is Linux it's a it's a
it's a
that is running a flavor of Linux and
here's the Ubuntu flavor again LS I can
see a file system I would slash root I
can run bash commands like whoops in
dollars LS do a and done sorry that's
just really obvious a primitive shell
scripting they're just on a full loop
over its iterated over each of the
directories as the result of LS against
the root filesystem and so it's it's
Linux for all intent and purpose if I
exit that container shut down and now we
can use the docker CLI a different
command PS which displays running docker
containers I have no container running
because I exited that but if I was to
change that give it an option of - a now
I can see all the containers that are
running all containers that have stopped
or have failed to start so you'll see
that that one there
Ubuntu command that executed was being
bash I was created a minute ago and
exited 16 seconds ago it's got a
container ID and a name so why did it
stop when I hit eggs when I typed exit
well the reason for that is that docker
a container in docker will be running a
single process and that container will
keep running until that process
terminates so we told it to execute bin
batch dump in a sh or I could have done
a variety of other binary executables
inside of there and once that process
stops the container stops but it's still
there so I could do docking of start and
then we give it the container ID you can
just give it an abbreviation the
container ID so just give it 22 and then
that start so if we do docker yes
obviously it's running again it started
it started up five seconds ago so now I
could do docker attach dead 22 I'm just
going to split my terminal wait for my
other ten will come up so you say I'm
back in at that prompt and then if I was
to do docker logs so a different
execute so this allows me to follow the
the standardout logging of the running
container we have it 22 and let's jump
back here and if we do LS you can see
that you know the the logs I'm getting
all the information that's happening
with inside of that container so that's
how I could observe what's happening on
container that I might not actually be
attached to now let's go back and kill
that and if we do docker stop so I can
issue commands at the container so I can
say docker stop I want to stop a
particular running container stop 22
that will send the appropriate and sig
term to it and that will turn that that
will in that process within their side
that container doing graceful exiting I
can do docker kill if I just want to
just terminate that process directly but
obviously you you probably if you're
wanting to stop a container you wanting
it to do a nice shutdown maybe not for a
layer running bash but something a
little bit more advanced you my I want a
proper shutdown for let's just clear out
my terminals and let's then the last
thing I might want to do I want to like
completely clean up what I had running
so I could do docker RM which is remove
and then remove what particular
container I can even I can provide it
the container ID or I can provide it the
container name it had a kind of a funny
name if we just back to yes Shea it's
got a funny name of Zilla spike I think
I could give it that name or I could
give it the container idea I basically
just have to give it something unique to
know how to terminate it so doctor REM
22 now if we Pierce - a we have no
running containers another useful
command docker images this shows me all
the images that I've got on my machine
so these are all the ones that I can
start obviously I can pull down new
images from a container registry that
could be docker hub which is the kind of
the open source container registry you
could have your own private container
registry inside of AWS inside of azure
inside a google cloud you could host one
yourself wherever whatever it might be
and you can pull those down but these
just containers that I've got on my
machine alright so let's go to the next
demo
I can run multiple containers from the
same image so here what I'm doing is I'm
sorry three different containers I'm
giving it a different argument that I
didn't have on the previous one which is
the dash D argument here - D says start
this container detached it's still an
interactive container
I can still attached to it but you're
not going to immediately bind my console
to it so I won't
I won't have an immediately accessed to
that container and - - erm I say it will
clean up their container when it when it
stops so let's just run that and I'm
gonna create a couple of shells alright
so while they all start up if we do your
docker PS see that we now have three
different ones here off actually the
other thing that I did with this one I
provided it with a - named argument this
allows me to control the name rather
than that automatically generated ones
all right this is ellos ellas pike which
it generated for me I might want to have
a bit more control over that something
that I can then use it's it's friendly I
know what it is
so in this case I've just called it AB 1
- 1 through 3 so now I can go doctor
attached to one to one and then down
here attached to one to 2 and docker
attached one two three okay so these are
all independent of each other they do
obviously look the same at the file
system because they've all started from
the same image they all started their
life identical but let's take one to two
here and if I do echo hello and they see
Oslo as redirect that out to food dot
txt oops
and if I could spell echo that would
help echo there we go
now if I think I have have that file
that I've obviously just created there
but if I was to come up to any of the
other ones
oops wrong one you'll see that the only
a bun - - has that file with inside of
its file system that's because each of
these containers is completely isolated
from the others it doesn't have access
to the files in it so I can create files
in one that no one else has access to
they're fully process isolated I could
do say a docker stop on Ubuntu 3 and
you'll see that it's done it's in the
sig term - that one down there of exit
that process is terminated the batch
process is terminated and that container
has shut down
so I'm now back at my wso prompt and if
I docker PS - hey I only see a bun - two
and two and one running because I
terminated one two three and the - - RM
meant it was going to automatically
remove itself once the process is
completed so I can easily then get rid
of all of them if I want to do if I do
dr. PS - q I get just the process IDs I
could then pipe that through to the
exercise command in Linux which just
takes the output of one process turns it
into argument so I can pipe to another
process and then docker stop and you'll
say that's cinch exit - both of the
others now all three of them done closed
and we have no more running or stopped
containers on my machine and time to
clean up all of our terminals all right
so let's go I've got 14 live demos so
I'm really hoping that the demo gods are
kind to me today and you're gonna see a
lot of git checkout so on to our next
one when people talk about what they can
do with containers they're they they
obviously talked about running micro
services in production air or container
izing legacy applications so that you
can have simpler deployments and stuff
like that but I actually think that
there's a big opportunity people don't
realize you can do with with containers
and that
is what I refer to as single-use
containers so let's say that I've got
something that I need to I've got an
executable I need to run but I don't
actually have that on my own
and when I first came across this I
realized that I could do this was I was
doing taking away interviews for the
company that I work for and we have a
candidate submit a code puzzle but we
review and talk to them about during the
interviewing process but this one
candidate had sent their puzzle or their
solution as a raw file this is in 2016 I
haven't paid for WinRAR license no I
don't have WinRAR much you know I don't
have 7-zip on my machine my machine is
completely transient if I if it dies I
just I pave it and start again I don't I
don't install software I don't need to
install like and who's using something
other than zip or as in as a archiving
format to just share things around or at
least as a bundling form I just couldn't
wrap my head around why would someone
would be using rah and I was like well I
I mean I need to unpack these files
right because I need to review it to
talk to the candidate about it but as
soon as I install 7-zip or WinRAR I know
that's putting stuff in the Windows
registry
I know it's putting stuff in random
locations all over the windows file
system and it's just even if I uninstall
immediately after like I could use
chocolaty or something like that to
install and uninstall but it it's still
going to leave things that I don't
really want left on my machine no matter
no matter how good you think the
uninstaller is it's always gonna leave
something behind
so like a good software engineer I
decided to work out how I could best
over engineer the solution to the
problem that I needed and that was to go
find a docker image that already had
Unruh inside of it found one on docker
registry I decided well I'm just going
to pull that down it's gonna do exactly
what I need so I found this one it's by
some person but it's inside of it it's
it's got Unruh that's all I need and I
know that this is going to clean up
nicely on my machine afterwards because
when I remove that when that container
stops I can have it auto remove
or I can remove myself and then I can
remove that image and all traces of
unrar is gone from my machine so let me
just clean up from when I last run this
to show you what the output would look
like so this command well so but this
doesn't also introduce another thing I
showed you in that last set of demos
that the file systems are unique per
container that's running if I create
something one Hallett like it's not
available to the others but I need to
get something off my laptop into the
file system of this running container
and we can do that with volumes so I
have a - V about middle of that command
there - V or double - volume if you want
the the long version of it then we
provided a path on my local file system
and then : and in the paths on the
containers file system that I want to
mount so what this will create is
essentially a mount point between your
file system and the container container
can then access files that are inside of
that folder and only that folders you
use specifically mounted as a volume it
can't access the rest of your file
system and then it can it can be mounted
in a read-only mode or mounted in a
readwrite by default it doesn't read
write which is what I obviously need for
this cuz I need to unwrap some files and
then I'm telling you I want to execute
the unwrap command that the self takes
some arguments and ultimately has to
take the file I want to unwrap so how
does that look well it's doing exactly
what it shouldn't have done which is
file awesome there's nothing like the
present for having demo files happen
let's just try one more delete of that
make sure it has well you'd think that
when I went right click delete on that
able to actually delete it but
apparently not so let's just try again
and thank you something is locking that
on my filesystem and this is gonna be a
really terrible demo if I can't actually
delete the files I need to delete well
let's give it one last crack and then I
will just move on to the next demo okay
so I've got something that's locking of
something on my file system but you
could kind of see the idea I unwrapped
has started up it has obviously detected
there's something on my file system that
it can't write over the top of so it's
just then bailed out hopefully you get
the idea and I don't get too much
sympathy from the fact that my demos are
failing already and we're only at number
three there's there's only nine more of
it none wait 11 more of these to go
I can math it's a little too early in
the morning okay so let's go to the next
demo all right so the idea of running
single process is with inside of
containers so that's highly useful as
you do also do a bunch of prototyping of
stuff that you maybe you don't want to
install things on your machine I've I
wanted to dabble with golang I'm not
sure if I want to become a go line
developer and write I don't quite
understand how the go ecosystem works
like that it and I don't want to do
something that's gonna mess up my
windows filesystem as I'm trying to do
fat's around and get going sword or
Python or Python 3 or to start both
because something's working one not the
other or all these kind of stuff well I
can pull down an image that has all that
set up inside of it and I can work with
inside of that image and then when I'm
done I can either destroy it and get rid
of it and blow away the container or I
can you know then choose to you know
actually install things on my bare metal
but I tend to put as much stuff into
containers as I possibly could so this
is how you could run node inside of a
container we just pull down the node
container and pulling down no so I'm
running again I've given it a name
this one is node but then it's got a
colon after it and then seven point
seven point four dash Alpine so when you
create an image and you push it to a
registry it's got two pits of
information it's got the image name in
this case no and then it's got the image
tag which is in this case seven seven
four - Alpine and tags really useful
because they allow you to have the the
same image name but different flavors of
that in this case seven seven four alpha
is the the version number
no that's going to be running with
inside of that container and then it's
this is using instead of using the
Ubuntu as the base OS for lack of a
better descriptor it's going to be using
a flavor of Linux called Alpine which is
much more a much better design for
production how does that look
just before we run this docker images
you'll see that I have both the node
ones here at Alpine and just seven seven
for draw you'll see that there's a bit
of a size difference between them 666
meg versus 59.2 meg so you probably only
I the the larger one might be more
useful if you're doing local development
you know it's it's got more debugging
stuff built into it but in production
you probably don't need all of that you
probably don't need this really large
image that's being spun up because
that's obviously going to consume more
memory when the container is running and
stuff like that so you might use a
different flavor and more slim down
specialized design for production sort
of our sort of image so if we let's
execute this and now I'm in and no
jeaious come in from because I'm
executing the node binary with inside of
a container so I can do console I can do
console log hello in DC although it's
just knowed I could get the file system
via require and we do if this reader of
slash and in paths whoops and
console.log paths so I've still got
access to it's just node like the the
same as if you in Cellino it on bare
metal and I can run it with you with
inside of a container I could have like
pretty much every permutation of node
version wise that won't know so if I if
I let's say I wanted to test something
against the the latest and the node ten
relators no.10 release but we weren't
sure if we were ready to put our
application from node eight to know ten
well maybe I could pull down the
container I could run the applet pull
down the image run the application with
inside of our contain
a container running load ten see where
errors might be without having to
install multiple versions of node use
like a nvm or something like that to
manage them locally that's that's one
other use for single use containers
right so beyond what we actually want to
run something with inside of our
application so I want to actually run an
application with inside of note I've
written a very complex node application
this isn't a node talk so if you know to
know developer I'm sorry this codes
probably gonna be really hard to
understand waits for the comedic effect
three two one
moves on it's it's basically it's a
basic web server bound to port 3000 that
we're gonna be running with inside of
our container so again I'm gonna do a
volume out volume out the current
working directory to slash source
I said the working directory which is a
dash W to the run command to slash SRC
because that's where my code is now
living then node will the the container
will start up it will run the node
binary with app J s as an argument so
we'll start my web server so if we just
run that cool I've also started this in
touch mode so we can see docker PS we'll
see that it's running you can see the
command that's executed it's it's up and
then if we were to curl HTTP localhost
3,000 and oh it's failed to connect then
we're actually meant for it to file so
that was fully expected because well
I've been I've said it's listening on
port 3000 but that's port 3000 on the
containers network but it's not on my
network not on my host network the host
doesn't even know that port Bunny exists
and we can see this if I do docker
inspects oops and oops that's not should
have been
where was that container ID 24 so that
command that I've just executed don't
worry if you're not following along with
that it's you know necessarily meant to
memorise that but basically it's a it's
a little go template that in rates
through a JSON payload to find a
particular section of that in this case
I'm looking for the ports that are bound
on the networks that this container has
available to it and the output of that
is blank because this container has no
ports bound to its network the node
process is bound to a port but that that
port is never exposed anywhere with
inside of our network so on to our next
demo if I want to have something is
running on a network that is allowing
inbound and outbound requests I need to
explicitly bind those ports I've added
an extra argument to this - P double -
port if you want the the long name and I
specify a port on my host bound to a
port on my container so in this case I'm
gonna bind port 808 o to port 3000 well
just get that running doctor I probably
should actually stop that one so it's
just do docker stop 24 give that a
moment I should just done a kill I
didn't actually need that to gracefully
shut down but it's gonna gracefully shut
down anyway and clean up in a any minute
now there we go let's run this again
okay so let's just run that docker
inspect command again and that's gonna
be on 76 so this time you'll see that I
do have an output of that because it
knows that I've bound that port port
3000 on TCP is bound to the the host
port of 808 oh and if I do a curl of
that again it's localhost
so containers are in in leith on Windows
pretty sure on Linux as well implicitly
bound to localhost so I I get from a
networking standpoint you can't control
the networking a bit more see that a
little bit later so that's how we know
we can connect to it the Paul
that you're binding on your local
machine it doesn't have to match the one
on the container as you've seen and that
can be really useful if you've got say
an application that's that's running and
it just wants to run on it port port 80
because that's what it runs with inside
of its container but you actually may be
sitting in gene X in front of it so
you're going to have some some redirects
happening and some or some other port
bindings so it might be locally bound to
some random port which then an nginx is
doing a port forward through to so
that's our lovely webserver it's like I
said it was a super complex bit of code
hey you didn't need to follow along but
that's how we can run a web server with
inside of a container okay so let's just
stop that one should I killed again now
I got to now we're gonna wait for node
to gracefully shutdown any minute now
just as I'm about to take a drink of
water it does gracefully closed well
that's nice so let's go to step seven so
far all we've done is we've been running
container running containers from images
that someone else is built even we might
even with that node one I was still just
running someone else's node can note
image myself and that's great for just
me but you're probably working with
other people and I mean the whole point
is that you want to be able to push
these through to production it after all
so you you probably want to make sure
that anything that you're doing locally
that you've got some kind of an output
that someone else can use and that's one
of the points of immutable
infrastructure that you can do here is
that the container sorry the image that
you get is it doesn't change and you
just move that through environments and
you change the config that's going to it
maybe you've set some environment
variables and that's how you've changed
a connection string to a database or an
API key for a service that it's using
with inside the application so to do
that we need to build an image so I've
introduced another command up here
docker build docker build is how we
build an image and this is also where we
introduce the docker file the docker
file is what we use to describe a series
of commands oh and execute against
containers to build up an image a docker
file always starts with a from directive
and that's the base image that we're
using images are always layered upon
other images so so we're always building
on top of something else that someone
has given us in this case I'm building
on top of the node 774 Alpine so from
image name and then providing a bunch of
information that we that we have so I'm
going to expose port 3000 I'm gonna
create a directory copy my Java
JavaScript file into that directory in
that image or in the container this
image is going to going to come from I'm
going to set the working directory
sorry working directory and then finally
execute a command when that container
starts up so we run that we'll see that
it's starting to process all those steps
one by one see from node and then
there's a there's an ID expose and then
you actually notice between this expose
under this expose we have running in and
then an ID and then removing so the way
a docker build actually works is it will
actually start up a container and
execute a command with inside of it
stop that container snapshot it and then
that's that what they call a layer to an
image and then we just keep rinse and
repeat all the way down so that goes all
the way through we eventually get to our
final one and it cleans up after itself
you can set flags so it doesn't clean up
after itself but you're not within this
kind of long tail of the images that are
not particularly useful and eventually
I've started my web server up so if we
do dr. PS you'll see it's running you
know the command is actually a little
bit different here because it's using
the same day directive with inside of
the docker file so it's executing been
SH with a string of a command to run in
this case it's executing node app J yes
we've been SH we've got our ports bound
etc etc if let's just stop this one for
the moment stop no stop B hey
because I want to show you another
really powerful part about images so
remember I said that images are all
built on top of each other they're
layered what that means is that if I was
to say reorder stuff I say that I
actually go well you know what I
probably should set the working
directory prior to the copy because then
I can just do copy it into dot instead
of copy it into source now if we do if
we run that we have a look at this
output you'll see that these first
couple it's actually got instead of
running in it says using cache because
what it's realized is that the the char
of that command that's being executed
inside of the can inside of a container
to produce the image is exactly the same
as another one that I've previously
created it's the exact same as another
layer so I'm actually reusing that it's
no point in craning it again I know I
know that these are these are identical
so I actually get a very much a much
faster build time because I don't have
to execute a whole bunch of stuff that's
previously been executed this is really
useful if you're building container
Building images that you have to install
a bunch of stuff in you know maybe you
are doing something that's going to use
the asp net core runtime on linux so you
have to install that you don't want have
to install that every single time it's
downloads and stuff that's it's just
that adds time into your build process
so I can reuse that layer from previous
so that's there's just how kind of how
image layering works let's just get rid
of that change
check out doctor file and let's just
stop that from running oops doc a
stalker kill one let's just kill it that
time because then it's gonna be faster
all right and we'll check out our next
step 8 all right so when you start
having even a moderately complex
environment you might be running a
couple of difference
containers need to talk to each other
they have ports bound and so on and so
forth and that and that could be I had
quite complex just command line command
line things that you have to execute you
end up with these really long you know
shell scripts or bat bat files or
PowerShell scripts or whatever your
scripting language of choices but there
is another way that we can do this and
that's what docker compose dr. who pose
I kind of have like a love-hate
relationship with it it it's very great
at describing what's happening with
inside of an environment but I just I
have this hatred of Gamal because it's a
yam or five I whites very significant
languages just something doesn't sit
right with me for those I'm more of a
web developer and JavaScript and yeah I
in deal with semicolons but wise face
significance is a bit more painful but
this is what a docker compose file looks
like it's basically the exact same thing
that we had when we're doing docker run
and then specify an image some arguments
except for etc but in this case I've got
a service that I'm starting out the
image that service is going to use is
the node seven seven for alpine I'm
specifying some port bindings on that
I'm mounting a volume which is the
current directory into slash source
working directory etc etc etc and then
to execute this we use docker compose
instead of just docker dr Posey's it's
kind of a separate product to docker
itself with Windows when you install
docker you get both doc and doc compose
if you installed docker on Linux I'm not
sure about Mac because I don't actually
have a Mac I've been at least on on
Linux when you install you don't get
docker compose you have to install that
separately I'm not quite sure why
there's that difference between them but
it's just worth noting so you're talking
a pose we specify the compose father
we're going to be using - f doc compose
- yeah Mille I'm saying that I want to
start up this environment so that's what
the the up command is and then I'm gonna
give this environment a name of node and
then it will do a bunch of stuff to to
do some prefixes onto them and we'll see
that in a moment and then finally I can
do da compose
RM and chef just kind of a force remove
and that's how we can shut down and
clean up an environment once we're done
with it so let's get this up and running
so we're creating a container from from
that you you see its given it a prefix
of the current directory doctor from
scratch and then the name that I
specified which is node and then a
suffix of one because it's the the first
service that it was starting and then if
we just have a look at our docker PS
you'll see that we have this this
container running it it's now just
running is plain old docker because the
reason for that is docker composes
really is is actually just translating
that Yama file into the appropriate CLI
commands to execute and now we can do
docker kill of f3 and by killing that
that stops the compose from running
which will in turn clean it up after
itself and we're all done and dusted so
we can do other things with docker
compose step 9
so let's say that we wanted to run
something to actually build an image out
of it obtain that second node example
that had where we had the docker file I
can use da compose to also execute a
docker file and then run a service on
the base of that so this time instead of
having to specify the image working
directory etc etc I can do all of that
in my docker file same docker file that
we saw previously and this time the node
service that I'm specifying here has a
build property on it on line 9 I specify
where what's the context of the builder
you want to execute it's in the current
working directory dot slash the docker
file is called docker file that's just
the convention is that you use docker
files the name of the docker file I'll
be you could call the file whatever you
want call it Fred if you prefer
and then I'm stressed fighting the
platform is gonna be Linux this is
running on I interesting sidenote about
document pose is I'm using the version
2.4 of da compose here
version 3.5 I think it's the latest one
it's least released version 3 is the
latest version of docker compose the
version 3 of docupace does not support
the platform directive so you can't say
that you differentially differentiate
between Windows and Linux containers in
docker compose version 3 but you can in
version 2 because versioning is hard so
that's why I'm still using version 2 for
this and then this will run exactly the
same as we would expect it it's running
out build I always say that we've been
we've used cache for basically the
entire thing because I had pretty much
all of that previously cached it's it's
up and running then yep there's a
webserver all very exciting docker PS
and we'll see that that's up and running
if I do docker images you'll see the
dock from scratch node at the top there
you'll see the node.js app directly
below which is the one then we created
by just executing the command line
docker docker build step ok and then
let's just kill kill of whatever you are
ok cool compose will shut down and we'll
check out
now we might want to be using docker
post do something that it just becomes a
bit more clunky to do with inside of a
command line and that is working with
environment variables we might have
multiple compose files for different
environments I said compose files can
actually lay it on top of each other and
what you'll see here is I'm running a
sequel server hopefully this will work I
just realized this is still in version 3
yeah this will still work so I want to
run the Linux version of Microsoft
sequel server now to run that I have to
provide an environment variable this as
I accept the License Agreement and I've
got to give it a super strong sa
password don't call me my password
please so I can start that up I do some
port binding but I could then have
multiple versions of this file then I
just changed the environment variable so
I have like a different si password for
the different environments or wait it
might be generators the output of a
build step the da compose file so don't
actually check in my production database
sa password to source control and then
publish that on an open public github
repo and all of a sudden my entire my
production infrastructure has been owned
but I can run this and that will take a
moment to startup link sequel server is
quite a large container to get up and
running that's it's about a 1.5 gig
download so I did that prior to coming
on to the conference Wi-Fi because
otherwise you'd be sitting here for
quite a while so there we go it's just
getting started and I'm just going to
open up a couple of files in link pad
that one all right so let's just
increase the font size zoom zoom my
pretties
alright and let's just refresh my
connection up here because I opened up a
link pad before the before the container
was fully started so I couldn't actually
connect to my sequel server but there we
go you probably see this
very small up here behind the magnifier
camera magnifier there we go so we go
it's a it's a completely empty sequel
server master model mr. bian empty B as
you would expect on an empty sequel
server so I can then execute this
against the right database connection
there we go now if we just refresh our
sequel server connection we refresh and
realize that something has not worked
and my demo is just failing me again
no the sa password did not match that is
interesting try that one more time
that's gonna be a real problem if my sa
passwords are not matching anyway in the
that is a very good point I am
connecting to the Thank You audience cuz
that was going to freak me out and I was
gonna have a lot of problems going
forward if I couldn't work that one out
BSI probably create the database before
I try and create a table in it order of
execution problems yeah we can deal with
those so this is taking a moment if we
come over here there's nothing
interesting in the logs but you kind of
see what's happening in our log files
there give it a moment that is taking a
phenomenal amount of time
alright that's airing for some reason
but I think you kind of get the point
that I should have been able to execute
these scripts but in the essence of time
I'm not going to sit here and try and
debug my life's failings
so let's kill that one and we'll just
jump over to our next
step step 11 yep to make that okay so I
said the docking impose is designed to
be used designs basically represent one
environment looks like an execute the
appropriate doctor CLI commands so what
if we had something that was maybe
running multiple environment multiple
containers I've got a web application
here and it talks to a sequel server I'm
fairly standard sort of architecture
yeah web and sequel and this is what the
doc you post file looks like it's a it's
a nice v-neck core application that I
build I this is actually all generated
by the visual studio templates or it was
when I gave this talk last time these
templates all seem to have changed
massively and this stuff doesn't work
but this is the general idea of what the
document post stuff looks like so I have
a service called demo app up the top
it's got a docker file that's going to
execute and it's going to by its import
and it's going to sit in two separate
networks one called web and one called
TB and then going to start up a sequel
server sequel server has a an outbound
port it's going to got an image we're
specifying some stuff like that and it's
going to live with inside of only the
sequel database but you'll see that on
line 24 I'm calling it demo app
underscore sequel is that the name of
the the container that I want to start
up but we're inside of that Network I'm
calling it sequel because I want some
way that I can refer to it from my from
my web application so you'll see here my
connection string just says it's going
to connect to a signal server called
sequel on the appropriate port blah blah
blah and that should all be up and
running but you can do that all just
from the standard command line step so
I'm doing a dhaniya build at the top
once that's completed we will do a
docker build to generate a container
that will run that that has the the
output of the dinette build with inside
of it we're then going to create a
network I'm calling it step 11 rather
than called web and sequel in this
within starting up a container on line
I'm specifying that the container is
going to live inside of is called step
it's going to be bound to port 11 13 and
37 it's going to go through to port 80
so the a spinet application and then the
sequel server is also with inside of
that that network sorry this time I've
actually just put them both with inside
of the same network so let's run that
and we wait for the air compile to take
hold luckily it's a very simple
application so it doesn't actually take
too long to run that's starting up we're
starting to build the docker image based
off of that so we see all of our layers
getting executed we're studying and
we're creating our network we're
starting our containers if we do docker
PS see that I have the sequel server and
we have the donut demo application if I
open up a browser
oops realize I didn't close my tabs not
my browser again and then we go to
localhost one three three seven
so hello world a spinet application I
want to register an account we'll give
it that and we'll give it a password and
we'll hit register but we have initially
created a database yet but this is
obviously worked that out ie it's
obviously been able to talk to the
database and go on well
the database that you're trying out
access has a light doesn't exist but
because I'm running this in development
mode in my container I can use the DAF
migrations I can apply those migrations
as your left link pad running
there we go if we have a look here
migrations should be done but out there
we go
now we've got a database it's got tables
with inside of it if I just reload this
page resubmit that form I'm now
successfully logged in so my web
application and my sequel server they're
able to talk to each other I'm able to
create stuff in those two environments
excellent so let's just go up and stop
those clean everything up and then we're
going to go to our next one as I'm
drastically running out of time we've
got a couple more demos to go all right
so I was running my sequel server of my
web server in the same network but
realistically you probably want to have
some kind of network isolation between
them we don't we probably don't even
want our sequel server externally
accessible I'm from a production
standpoint we probably want to we want
to block all incoming port incoming
traffic through that sequel server just
to reduce one one of the attack vectors
so to do that we can create them in two
separate networks and we don't actually
have to do any public port bindings so
in this case I'm creating two networks
step 12 - called web and underscore
sequel to me the web application will
live in the web network the sequel
database will live in the sequel Network
but I'm then going to here on line 24
I'm going to connect the sequel Network
to the web container so so how that
looks then if we run we'll come back up
here and if we do give that a moment now
figure out it actually has to rebuild
the application again because my script
wasn't enough to say if there's a
previously done build output everything
is up and running now we have the
containers up and running so we can do
dr. Pierce we see that they're both
there now you'll see that the sequel
server it's bound on port 14 4833
but only internally it doesn't have a
host port binding like the one below it
0 0 0 1 0 0 0 local port port forwarding
through to port 80 I don't have a local
host port binding to that so inside of
link pad if I was to refresh my
connection to the database it's going to
timeout because I have no ability to
access that that container sorry no that
container yeah I know no access to that
sequel server but my website if we come
back to localhost there we go that one
at a moment register with a password
whoops
so my web server is still able to talk
to it because they're in the same
network it's been connected to the
signal servers network that cycle server
is exposing yourself on part 14 33 on
its own network but not to its host so
this is how you can do networks to
separate separation and isolation so I
can have that set there and kind of use
fairly standard diems edge sort of setup
that you might have in production
sounds like someone else's finish which
means that I have only a few minutes
left to go and to more demos so it's
jumped forward to step 13 now I said at
the start I had a joke in the title
which is that this is docker from
scratch and the reason that I say from
scratch is scratch is the most primitive
image that you can create a container
from it's technically not an image like
you can't actually pull it down from a
container registry but you can still
build something from it scratch has
nothing installed in it by default where
we used a bun to previously and I was
able to connect into and do using bash
and then I could execute commands
against it it's got a few other premier
things in there
it's got like apt if you want to be able
to install some additional soft
- you container scratch has doesn't have
that it doesn't even have Sh
so you cannot like you can create an
interactive container of scratch but you
can't connect into it cuz it's got no
processes with inside of it to run so I
want to how you can use scratch so I
want to create a really simple binary
that I can chuck into a scratch
container so I've done that with go goes
the easiest one that easiest language I
know to create a just a native binary
that I can execute I have a super
complex go application here which says
hello world I use docker run to do I
build in a go line container which is
what I'm doing up on line 5 that will
output me a binary and then I will build
using the docker file I will run that
container and that docker for that
container that's from scratch the only
thing it will have inside of it is the
go is the output of the go build so
let's run that so it's going superfast
and then I've got to clean up afterwards
let me actually just remove the let's
get rid of that line dude you will just
run it again I just don't want to show
you how this looks so if I do docker
images so we have this DFS - scratch 1.5
Meg that's how big that images so it can
be really highly performant to use
scratch in a production scenario because
it's it's tiny and you can run a lot of
these in parallel then let's just undo
my changes and then let's go to our
final demo with three minutes to spare I
actually added this final demo since
I've done the last last time we've done
the talk so I wasn't sure I was going to
get to it but something that's fairly
recent - - docker and kind of the last
sort of six months I think it was they
added this ability to do what they call
multi-stage docker files
so dr. Falls traditionally you could
have one from directive at the top and
then you have a bunch of stuff and that
would produce you an image at the end so
if you wanted to use do like I say I
said a process like the asp net core
does when you're using docker files in
that did you do building one you take
the output of that and your push it into
another container
oh sorry another image and we were doing
that without going we're all building in
one will push in that build output to
our scratch well with a multi-stage
docker file I could have all of those in
the single file and I'll get an image
with that is using the very final from
directive as where we starting so now I
start with from go line 1.8 and I'm
saying as build so this is going to be
the build image I said working directory
copying some files execute the go build
and then I'm able to here on line 11
oops I'm able to copy files from a
previously created container into this
new container that's running to produce
my final image and that can be really
powerful if you've got like you you want
build output that you can just move
across or you you want something that
that happens inside of one container
that never ends up on the file system of
the host you can do some really good
isolation in that and this works exactly
the same as the other one we just have
our builds we have a slightly different
bit of an output because we have these
two containers and then I've done a
whole bunch of delete and cleanup and
that one I used a total of three make to
run those two taça files side by side
all right so we've one minute to spare
when my slides do pop back up
scratch from scratch where we saw this
talk and it's it's not particularly
useful because it's actually really hard
to use is just a baseline image but you
know it can be used for really high
performing containers that you want to
run images are great for experimenting
pull it down play around the container
that's running off an image of their
language you want to experiment with a
an application that you wanted to test
and stuff like that and then destroy it
at the end and you don't have to worry
about polluting your local file system
compose is a great way to represent
environments but you can actually just
do that all via the standard commands
and it's good to good to understand that
you know what the compose file actually
finally represents thank you unfortunate
I think we're out of time for questions
but I'll be around if you want to ask
any anything but thanks for attending